Europas Raumfahrt soll größer werden wir
sollen einen eigenen Zugang zum Weltraum
bekommen die raumerkundung voranbringen
neue Trägerraketen entwickeln und dabei
eine grünere Zukunft einleiten das haben
die zuständigen Minister der Mitglieds
und Kooperationsländer der ESA sich
gerade vorgenommen das klingt zwar alles
richtig cool aber ja auch richtig teuer
vielleicht zu teuer unter allen
weltraumvos von uns finden wir immer
wieder dieselbe Frage sollten wir das
viele Geld nicht lieber in andere Dinge
stecken z.B die Klimakrise die
biodiversitätskrise oder den Welthunger
und ja das ist eine gute Frage und genau
deshalb schauen wir uns heute mal an was
die Raumfahrt eigentlich wirklich kostet
ob Einsparungen an der Raumfahrt eine
Lösung für andere Probleme wären und
warum du ganz persönlich viel mehr von
der Raumfahrt profitierst als du denkst
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen Video
auf Dr
Watson ganz kurz mit Planet wild könnt
ihr Naturschutzprojekte finanziell
stützen und spätestens vier Wochen
später in einem Video sehen was euer
Beitrag in der Natur bewirkt hat und
weil das eine verdammt gute Sache ist
schenke ich den ersten 200 Personen von
euch den ersten Monat bei Planet wild
bleibt also bis zum Ende dran und jetzt
geht's los mit dem
Video das ist das Space Launch System
der NASA 2022 brachte die Rakete das
Raumschiff Orion für die erste
atemismission in den Weltraum Rakete
Raumschiff und Bodenstation haben die
NASA zusammen
50 Milliarden USDollar gekostet jeder
Staat kostet noch einmal 4 Milliarden
Dollar mehr die ISS dürfte inzwischen
über 200 Milliarden Dollar gekostet
haben das James Web Teleskop wird über
seine Lebenszeit 11 Milliarden Dollar
kosten und auch die aktuellen Missionen
zum Mars und zum Jupiter kosten jeweils
mehrere Milliarden Dollar solche
Missionen sind also teuer klar
schließlich wird unglaublich viel
Aufwand betrieben um unglaublich
komplizierte Hightech Apparate zu bauen
und damit unglaublich viel Treibstoff
auf nimmer Wiedersehen in den Weltraum
zu schießen aber wenn wir uns die Frage
stellen ob uns die Raumfahrt zu teuer
ist oder wir das Geld für etwas
Wichtigeres ausgeben sollten dann
sollten wir uns nicht die einzelnen
Missionen anschauen sondern die
jährlichen Kosten die westlichen
Industrienationen plus China Japan und
Indien haben 2022 zusammen 94 Milliarden
Euro für die Weltraumforschung
ausgegeben das klingt vielleicht nach
viel ist im Vergleich zu den
Gesamtausgaben der Länder aber
tatsächlich Peanuts z.B Deutschland
Deutschland zahlt etwa 20% des Budgets
der Europäischen Weltraumagentur ESA
sowie das komplette Budget des DLR und
noch ein paar kleinere Projekte für das
alles haben wir 2022 rund zieinhalb
Milliarden Euro ausgegeben aber die
Gesamtausgaben Deutschlands betrugen im
selben Jahr rund 495 Milliarden Euro die
Raumfahrt macht in Deutschland also nur
ein halbes Prozent der Staatsausgaben
aus selbst die USA die 60% der
weltweiten Ausgaben für raumfahrtprogram
tragen stecken weniger als 1% der
Staatsausgaben in die Raumfahrt die
Verteidigungsausgaben waren im Vergleich
dazu in Deutschland 22 Mal und in den
USA 12 Mal so hoch wie die Ausgaben für
die Raumfahrt Raumfahrt hat also nicht
die Priorität die man bei all den großen
Summen intuitiv erwarten würde okay aber
wäre das Geld nicht trotzdem besser in
den Kampf gegen den Welthunger
investiert Schätzungen von Experten
sagen ja sogar dass man nur 20 bis 50
Milliarden Euro pro Jahr in die
richtigen Entwicklungs Programme stecken
müsste dann wäre der Welthunger bis 2030
gegessen und es wäre ja viel weniger
Geld als die Raumfahrt kostet die großen
Industriestaaten könnten das also easy
locker machen warum sie das nicht tun
keine Ahnung wir unterstellen hier keine
Böswilligkeit aber Politik ist
tatsächlich komplizierter als
Raketenwissenschaft wir können nur
feststellen dass wir Welthunger haben
liegt nicht daran dass wir lieber
raumfahrtponsoren so einfach ist das
nämlich leider nicht was wir aber
erklären können ist warum Staaten in die
Raumfahrt investieren sollten wir
schießen die 94 Milliarden Euro ja nicht
zum Spaß in den Himmel na ja nicht nur
zum Spaß teilweise schießen wir die 94
Milliarden Euro nämlich doch zum Spaß in
den Himmel wir finden schwarze Löcher
cool und ihr findet schwarze Löcher cool
und deshalb können wir davon leben
Videos über Raumfahrt zu machen wir alle
profitieren also direkt von der
Forschung zum Weltraum und das gilt
natürlich auch für andere Formate und
vielleicht inspirieren die spektakulären
weltraumprogramme ja den einen oder die
andere in die Wissenschaft zu gehen und
neue spannende aber auch nützliche Dinge
herauszufinden oder tolle neue
Technologien zu entwickeln und genau
solche Leute brauchen wir ganz dringend
denn vor allem Ingenieure haben wir in
vielen europäischen Ländern zu wenige
klar wir brauchen die Ingenieure für die
Erneuerung der Infrastruktur vor allem
für Klimaschutz und Klimaanpassung aber
auch in diesen Bereichen leisten die
Raumfahrtagenturen einen Beitrag
schließlich setzt die Raumfahrt schon
seit den 50er Jahren auf Technologien
wie Solarzellen und
wasserstoffbrennstoffzellen und leistet
seitdem Entwicklungsarbeiten an diesen
klimaneutralen Technologien sie vermehrt
aber auch unseren Wohlstand in den
letzten Jahrzehnten haben viele
Erfindungen aus der Raumfahrt ihren Weg
in unseren Alltag gefunden akkuwerkzeuge
Handykameras kabellose Kopfhörer
LED-Lichter aber auch so Dinge wie
Feuermelder feuerbeständige Materialien
Teflonbeschichtung uvfilter und die Gold
und silbernen Rettungsdecken im erste
hilfekasten außerdem moderne Prothesen
kontaktloses Fiebermessen
gesundheitsmonitoring mobile
Ultraschallgeräte und viele viele andere
medizinische Geräte und auch die Suche
nach Lösungen für die Bewältigung
aktueller Krisen profitiert von der
Raumfahrt für den Langzeitaufenthalt im
Weltraum werden z.B Technologien
entwickelt um Nahrung saubere Luft und
sauberes Wasser in einem geschlossenen
Kreislauf bereitzustellen damit könnte
man auf der Erde in unwrdlichen Regionen
nachhaltig die Ernährungssicherheit
gewährleisten ich könnte stundenlang
Erfindungen aus der Raumfahrt auflisten
die unser allerle Leben verbessern
schaut gerne mal auf den Seiten von der
ESA von der Nase und vom DLR da kann man
ewig herumstöbern und mehr über diese
vielen faszinierenden Erfindungen
herausfinden wir haben das alles mal
unten in der Videobeschreibung verlinkt
der Punkt ist wenn Ingenieure
Technologien für Extremsituationen
entwickeln dann bekommt man dabei die
tollsten Erfindungen und es werden nicht
nur Gadgets erfunden auch
Grundlagenforschung wird im Weltraum
betrieben also Forschung die Fragen über
die Welt beantwortet wie wirkt sich die
Gravitation auf Lebewesen aus wie
verändert sich flüssigkeitsdynamik in
Mikrogravitation was ist dunkle Materie
und was passiert auf anderen Planeten
egal ob Astrobiologie Astronomie Chemie
oder Materialkunde täglich werden im
Weltraum Experimente durchgeführt die
unser Verständnis über die Welt
erweitern allein auf der wurden schon
tausende von Experimenten durchgeführt
und dieses Wissen ist die Basis für neue
Technologien in der Zukunft sofortigen
Nutzen ziehen wir aus Satelliten GPS und
Kommunikationssatelliten lassen sich
kaum noch aus unserem Alltag wegdenken
und auch die Erdbeobachtung ist super
wichtig Wettersatelliten wie der MTG i1
von der ESA z.B da war ich übrigens beim
Launch dabei und das Video dazu könnt
ihr euch hier angucken die helfen uns
nicht nur das Wochenende besser zu
planen sondern sind vor allem für die
Luft und die Schiffahrt und die
Agrarwirtschaft super wichtig sie können
nämlich vor extremwetterereignissen
warnen und helfen so sichere Routen für
Flugzeuge und Schiffe zu ermitteln und
den Katastrophenschutz zu aktivieren und
Extremwetter werden wegen der globalen
Erwärmung ja immer häufiger und um den
Status des Klimas und andere Aspekte der
Erde zu überwachen brauchen wir
Langzeitbeobachtung aus dem Weltall z.B
misst der NASA Satellit SWAT den Anstieg
des Meeresspiegels und die Entwicklung
von Gewässern auf der ganzen Erde
insgesamt beobachten über 100 Satelliten
die Erde und sammeln unter anderem Daten
über die chemische Zusammensetzung und
Verschmutzung der Atmosphäre über
Niederschläge und Temperaturen ein Gerät
auf der ISS miss sogar die Höhe aller
Bäume mit einem leidersystem Satelliten
erkennen aber auch wie viel Methan
ölbohinseln wirklich freisetzen und sie
geben Hinweise auf kriminelle Handlungen
wie das Fischen in verbotenen Gewässern
oder Menschenhandel und natürlich sieht
man damit auch die Bewegungen von
militärverbänden insgesamt sind
Satelliten also auf vielen Ebenen super
wichtig für Transport und Logistik im
weltweiten Handel für die Landwirtschaft
für die internationale Sicherheit und
für Ökologie und geoforsschung auch
geopolitisch ist Raumfahrt ein Faktor
allerdings vielleicht nicht mehr so wie
wir es in den 90er Jahren noch gehofft
hatten da hieß es dass die
internationale Zusammenarbeit an
Raumfahrtprojekten die Welt
zusammenbringen
könnte daran lässt sich inzwischen
leider zweifeln denn die USA haben China
aus Angst vor Spionage von Kooperationen
im Weltall ausgeschlossen und die
Zusammenarbeit auf der ASS hat brussland
nicht daran gehindert antiwestliche
schwurbelpropaganda zu verbreiten der
Nutzen für die Staaten auf dem
internationalen Paket ist deshalb
vielleicht eher der
Schwanzvergleich denn technische
Meisterleistungen fördern das Ansehen
einer Nation sowohl bei der eigenen
Bevölkerung als auch international das
ist vielleicht kein tolles Argument und
hat diese unschönen nachkriegsvibes aber
es ist uns dann doch lieber wenn die
Nationen mit Punktlandungen auf
Asteroiden oder Robotern auf dem Mond
und Mars angeben statt mit
Interkontinentalraketen und
Atomsprengköpfen insgesamt kann man
sagen die Raumfahrtprogramme bringen uns
wissenschaftliche Erkenntnisse
technologischen Fortschritt und
satellitengestützte Dienstleistungen auf
die wir einfach nicht verzichten können
der eserchef sagte dass jeder Euro den
ein Staat in die Raumfahrt investiert 3
bis 10 € Profit bringt Weltraumforschung
und Raumfahrt lohnen sich also schon
rein
finanziell also ist das Geld in der
Weltraum schlecht angelegt zunächst
einmal würde man die Raumfahrt und die
Weltraumforschung beenden würde uns das
vermutlich keinen Schritt weiter im
Kampf gegen den Welthunger bringen denn
wenn es nur um Geld ginge dann könnten
die großen Industrienationen den
Welthunger auch beenden ohne die
Raumfahrt einzustampfen wahrscheinlich
könnten sogar ein paar Milliardäre das
Problem privat lösen stattdessen leisten
die Weltraumforschung und die Raumfahrt
auf verschiedenen Wegen einen Beitrag zu
Wohlstand Gesundheit und im Kampf gegen
globale Krisen schon allein deshalb weil
die Ausgaben für die ESA auch direkt
wieder in europäische Unternehmen und
damit Menschen in Europa fließen am Ende
gibt es also keinen ökonomischen
ökologischen oder sozialen Grund an der
Raumfahrt zu sparen zum Glück denn die
Erforschung des Weltraums ist ja auch
die Erfüllung des menschlichen Drangs
die Welt zu entdecken und ich würde
ungern darauf verzichten mehr über das
Universum zu lernen und dabei immer
wieder ins Staunen zu geraten jetzt
fragt ihr euch vielleicht wie
umweltfreundlich die Raumfahrt
eigentlich generell ist wie viel CO2
geht bei so einem Raketenstart in die
Luft genau dazu haben wir schon mal ein
Video gemacht das könnt ihr euch hier
anschauen und bevor ihr jetzt wegklickt
gebe ich euch noch eine wichtige Info
mit auf den Weg denn die Natur und ein
Team aus Berlin brauchen eure Hilfe
Planet wild ist eine
Naturschutzorganisation die jeden Monat
ein großes Projekt durchführt um unseren
Planeten zu schützen und die Schäden zu
beheben die die Menschen der Natur
zufügen ihre Projekte sind aber auf die
monatlichen Beiträge einer Community
angewiesen die die Erhaltung unserer
Ökosysteme unterstützen möchte es gibt
viele Möglichkeiten Geld für Naturschutz
zu geben aber hier werden die Projekte
sogar in coolen Videos auf dem
YouTube-Kanal von Planet wild
dokumentiert und so seht ihr direkt was
mit euren Beiträgen wirklich erreicht
wurde außerdem werden auch interessante
Tipps gegeben wie z.B du selber eine
Permakultur errichten kannst das habe
ich so vorher noch nicht gesehen und
unter anderem deswegen bin ich selbst
Teil der Community wenn ihr das auch so
seht und Teil dieser Community werden
wollt dann habe ich jetzt noch was ganz
besonderes für euch denn die ersten 200
Personen die sich über den Link in der
Videobeschreibung bei Planet anmelden
kriegen von mir persönlich den ersten
Monat bezahlt es lohnt sich also schnell
zu sein und vor allem lohnt es sich für
den Planeten danke fürs zuschauen und
wie immer bleibt neugierig euer srick